انتم موجود هنا في الدوحه ماذا عن لقائكم
بالطرف الامريكي
الامريكي لمده يومين موريتالي يومين
والمفاوضات انتهتميه بصوره رائعه وكانت
الاجواء ايجابيه جدا
واستمعنا الى قلقهم
وهم ايضا مستمعون الى افكارنا ومقترحاتنا
وحسب اتفاق الدوحه على الولايات المتحده
تحترم السياده الوطنيه
وان لا يكون هناك تحليق طائرات دون الطيار
في الاجواء الافغانيه وان يقوم او تقوم
الاداره الامريكيه بشكل القائمه السوداء
وان يكون هناك تعامل ايجابي مع الحكومه
الجديده وافغانستان نحن قمنا بتنفيذ في ما
جاء في اتفاق الدوحه ماذا تقصد باجواء
ايجابيه كان هناك
الايجابيه بان الجانب الامريكي يريد ان
يكون هناك تعامل بين طرفين نحن نريده
وايضا تريد ان تتعامل مع الحكومه الجديده
واعتقد ان الامور تمشي في الاتجاه في صحيح
وان الحكومه الحاليه تريد التعامل
الايجابي في الناحيه السياسيه والاقتصاديه
مع المجتمع الدولي والولايات المتحده
وان لا يكون هناك حرب في افغانستان وان
لدينا سياستهم
بمعنى عليها نريد ان نتعامل مع العالم ام
لا تكون افغانستان مسرحا للتنافس السلبي
بين الاتراك وان يكون هناك الاستثمار في
افغانستان وان يكون هناك علاقات السياسيه
المتبادله هل معنى ذلك ان هناك اليه في
اللقاء مع طرف الامريكي لدينا قنوات
وهناك اليه واضحه
للجلوس والمفاوضات
الولايات المتحده وهناك قضايا عده يتم
مناقشتها اثناء هذه المفاوضات والاجتماعات
وتطرقنا اثناء الاجتماعات لقضاء عديده تهم
كلا الطرفين مشكله كبيره وان 20 سنه
الماضيه واثناء الاحتلال الاجنبي
جاءت جامعات ارهابيه كبيره وكثيره الى
افغانستان
وانها كانت تستهدف
القوات الاجنبيه وانها كانت تعمل دعايات
بان هناك قاعده موجوده
وحركات مسلحه اخرى في المقابل اذا كانت
تكون
بقصف سوى القرى والرياض وان هناك جهاز
تقوم يعني ببث الدعايه وتقارير ومعلومات
خاطئه وهي تقومني ببيع هذه المعلومات
الخاطئه للدول الجوار الولايات المتحدهمون
هذه التقارير في تصريحاتهم وفي اتخاذ
مواقفهم منا وماذا عن ملف الاسرع من ملفات
المهمه
الحكومه
لا بد ان مبادي وانها تتعامل بناء على هذه
هذا الاسود والقواعد مع العالم واذا يكون
هناك المواطنين اجانب المعتقلين في
افغانستان ولكننا نريد ان نحل من هذه
المشكله وهذا الملف في صوره يعني يناسب
لكلا الطرفين وهناك قنوات خاصه وهناك
دوائر رسميه وهناك اجهزه امنيه
تتعامل مع هذا الملف بان حركه طالبان
تتدخل فيما يتعلق بتوزيع المساعدات لماذا
تردون هذه هي المساعدات والمنحطات الى
مواساه دوليه واجنبيه وهي التي تكون
بنفسها بتوزيعها وليس لنا اي دور في توزيع
هذه الاموال ان الشعب الافغاني
وهذه
تهمه
او
الحكومه الافغانيه ونحن لا نقوم بصرف هذه
المشاهدات ونحن لا نتدخل في توزيع اي
مساعدات انسانيه
فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف ملف حقوق الانسان
في افغانستان مقارنه باي فتره ماديه
الحقوق الانسان في افغانستان في فتره
ذهبيه جدا سابقا كان هناك يوميا لا تخسر
نحمل نحو 300 شخص حياته خلال الوجود
الامريكي والان لا نستقبل المستشفيات لا
تستكمل الجرحى والقتلى وكان هناك مداهمات
ليليه ومداهمات عسكريه
وكانت الافغانيه غير امنه وبعد وصولنا الى
السلطه فسلم تجري حادث امني في طول البلاد
وارضها ماذا عن الوضع المراه وايضا هذه
الانتقادات الموجهه بشكل مستمر من قبل
المجتمع الدولي حركه طالبه
يحاولون تقديم صوره سلبيه عامه
ويقومون بمحاوله تشويه سمعتنا بين الكثير
من النساء الافغانيات لديهم اعمالهم
الخاصه ولديهن شركات واما الحكومه
الافغانيه تقوم بدفع رواتبهما لكل امراه
امراه جلست في بيتها وان هناك عدد كبير من
الممرضات والتطبيقات تعمل في اطار وزاره
الصحه
ماذا فعلتم وتفعلون من اجل الانفتاح على
المجتمع الدولي وبالتالي التخفيف من هذه
الاعباء الاقتصاديه
خلال 20 سنه الماضيه جاءت المساعدات كبيره
جدا الى افغانستان
ولكنها لم تصرف كما كانت يجب وعندما سقطت
الحكومه والحكومه السابقه
فراينا انه لم تكن هناك البنيه اللازمه
لتقويه الاقتصاد الافغاني وانه هناك بعض
التقدم في بعض المجال والان نحن بدانا
ببناء البن تحته في افغانستان مثل الشوارع
والنظمي الافغانيه الان هي يعني
بثبات مقارنه بالعمله في المنطقه وان
الاسعار الى حد المسيطر عليها وان التجاره
ازدهرت بعد وصولنا الى السلطه ونحن فتحنا
الطريق الى كل رجال الاعمال والتجار ماذا
عن هذا التوتر عن ازمه المياه مع ايران مع
ايرانيبلوماسيه
والسفير الايراني موجود في كابول ولدينا
العصافير في طهران
لم كبيره
حتى بها اعلى هذه العلاقات
كان ملك مهم جدا ولكن هناك كل منطقه تعاني
من الجفاف وان منشوب المياه تراجع
وليس فقط في افغانستان
[موسيقى]